foreign
let's go to Lynn in Portland Oregon
what's up Lynn
hi Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call of course thank you for calling
what's up
okay uh two very important pieces of
information you need to know
one of them in my question initially I
have borderline personality disorder and
I also have a traumatic brain injury TBI
what happened
uh I got hit by a car when I was 17. oh
man
is is the effects like or the effects
neurological are they are they are they
ongoing
yes it's permanent it was originally
labeled as severe I think when I got a
little older they bumped it down to
moderate uh but I do struggle with like
memory loss
um my uh frontal lobe was pretty badly
damaged so was my temporal lobe so
memory decision making executive
functioning in general is not
um the best
you are an impulsive young lady aren't
you
[Laughter]
um okay so were you diagnosed with
borderline before this or has this been
a result of
the traumatic brain injury
bipolar two which they should not have
done I was too young I was gonna say
good Lord
yeah and uh why I ended up going to the
mental hospital back in 2020 and that's
when they realized
um just so you know you have borderline
personality disorder and whoever
diagnosed you with bipolar did not do
their research yeah
yeah
um
there's so many things here so many
things
um so let's let's go back so you had you
had a pretty chaotic childhood
okay
kind of
um like my dad and my grandmother died
when I was pretty young and they were at
three months apart me and my brother
were pretty young I was I just started
Middle School okay hold on hold on hold
on hold on
I just asked did you have a pretty
chaotic childhood and you said kind of
my grandma and my dad died as I was
entering middle school so let's just
stop there
you had a very chaotic childhood
a painful traumatic childhood
okay
can we sit on that for one second
yeah it was hard huh
it was yeah it is
Fair
yeah that is fair what was your dad's
name
Chris do you miss him
what's that do you miss him
oh every day
so let's I don't want you to gloss over
it I want us to let's just it's as
uncomfortable as it is let's let's own
reality okay it's hard and then my guess
is
um
your mom was struggled a lot huh
oh yeah like my grandmother that was her
mom my mom was never the same after my
grandmother died yeah or her husband
right well they were divorced yeah
uh was your childhood chaotic kinda I
came from a divorced home and then my
dad good night so yes yes I bet your
Aces what's your Aces score have you
ever taken that
I've taken what your Aces score
no I don't even know what that is it's a
10 question questionnaire it's the
adverse childhood experiences I want you
to take it when you get off my guess is
just listening to you yours will be
a six or a seven you
your body has been struggling to find
its place in space since you were very
very little Fair
yeah and I bet as a child you shouldered
a lot of I can I guarantee you did
because just how you answered the first
question that whether you were wondering
why they got divorced why daddy chose to
leave when Mommy kicked him out what
happened to Dad why did Grandma die like
all that as a young kid
you were trying to figure out what you
did to make some of those things happen
or what role you played in some of those
things Fair
yeah sometimes okay
so then you have this traumatic brain
injury and what happened were you
driving another car were you walking
across the road what happened
um I was crossing the street and I have
to say it harsh was my fault simply on
the fact that I was jaywalking and I
lost was a four-lane road and I got to
the last Lane and I got hit by somebody
I went flying over their windshield and
uh yeah it almost killed me yikes man
I'm glad you're all right
and so what took you to a um
to a psych Hospital in 2020.
I was living with somebody
um my cousin and we were drinking a lot
I mean I'm talking multiple bottles a
day and it got to the point where we
were just enabling each other and one
day I just couldn't take it anymore and
I was just in a very dark head space and
I realized I can't do this anymore
because if I don't go get help I'm gonna
slit my throat or I'm gonna do something
I don't know what but I need help and I
went twice that summer
um for both a three-day stay each time a
voluntary well I went I chose to go um
so I could leave whenever I wanted I
kind of wish I would have stayed a
little longer at the time because I had
the means to do so I can't say I have
that now but okay
eat now I think about going back
sometimes hmm
are you still are you still
um actively suicidal
you know am I taking my meds my am I in
my routine little things like that to
make a big difference but okay
okay some days it just comes on and I'm
not even prepared to feel crappy it just
happens yeah I
um it's really important to me that you
call somebody after this and you get
checked in
okay
and that's just because I love you
and I want you to be all right okay
okay
do you promise that you'll do that
I swear okay
um so how can I help you right now well
I have gotten to this point where I've
been
a bit out of control and by that I mean
I've been getting more aggressive
towards my partner I've been yelling and
screaming and calling them names and
getting in his face and and just not
being a very nice person to him and it's
affecting our relationship pretty badly
and
I just I just don't want to be like that
anymore like I it seems to be a common
Trend when I live with somebody some
conflict happens and then we're fighting
and yelling and screaming but I'm
usually the one who's fighting and
yelling and screaming right well and
that's one of the cornerstones of
borderline which makes it so hard is
this sense that you feel everything 100x
with everybody around you is feeling
so when you meet somebody for the first
time and you kind of have like man I
think I think she's she's pretty good
looking man and I kind of like her you
freaking love me I love you I'll sleep
with you right now and it's right and
and then when it's like a disagreement
like God that's annoying
you're like I'm gonna burn you to the
ground right I'm gonna kill you and your
family and and so it's this am I right
it's a thousand have you spot on it's a
thousand X for somebody with borderline
and that's what makes it so hard is
somebody who wants to heal now I want to
hold a big caveat here you have a
traumatic brain injury if you've got
permanent damage to parts of your brain
this may be something that you wrestle
with for the rest of your life and
that's okay that's just part of it right
I've got I had a knee surgery like I'm
not gonna go play basketball anymore and
I loved playing pickup basketball I'm
just not gonna do anymore I gotta I'd
agree that it's a bummer now is that the
same thing as like uh
the hippocampal injury or frontal lobe
injury no you'll have more stuff to do
with but it's just it's just the cards
you were dealt and let's roll with it
right and so I hope you hear I'm I'm
speaking with that light of a yeah this
is the this is the cards I got right and
so I'm Gonna Roll with that I'm not
going to go to war against those cards
because all that does is make me and
everybody around me miserable the
challenge for somebody with borderline
is I have to choose to feel less
intensely
I have to choose to begin to parse
through our feelings and it feels so
good to be in love
and it feels so good to be enraged those
are drugs right and you have to choose
to like get off those drugs does that
make sense
oh well absolutely it's so frustrating
have you been through rounds of DBT
dialectical dialectical behavior therapy
a little bit
um my current therapist who I recently
got switched to he is oh hey hold on
don't be a borderline Switcher
every okay every therapist knows that
when you get somebody and they sit down
they go you're the best
therapist I've ever had in my life my
last seven therapists they all sucked
they were the worst in whatever everyone
knows well looks like you got a
borderline here and you just gotta hang
on for the ride until you turn on them
how many have you been through
me yes um not very many um but pretty
um good relationships with my therapist
it always just came down to my last two
therapists had a different job or got
different jobs and they had to leave
okay you just made okay I thought you
were burning through them all right I
take back what I just said not at all
all right I was wrong you were right way
to go so
um you got a new therapist and you like
him and tell me more
um he's certified um the Keynotes how to
do
the my doctor's office who hold a lot
less intensive of a program compared to
like the Portland DBT Institute
um but on our last visit he told me that
I should find a way to make some space
for a more inpatient I don't know if
it's impatient or outpatient but a more
intensive program because he's worried
about me he's worried about my
impulsivities and my um on all my out of
control out of control Behavior we've
talked a lot about it we've talked a lot
about the yelling and the screaming and
the and the name calling and just the
outright just his poor Behavior I've
been showing lately and it's are you
self-harmed
me no I mean no I don't like cut or burn
myself or do any of that stuff but I
suppose I self harm in the sense of like
I don't really dig into my hobbies like
I should or just watch TV a lot or do a
lot of monotonous activities because
it's all I feel like I have time for for
the energy for why
why don't you think Lynn deserves peace
they're on chaos my whole life because
it's hard to feel like I can have some
quiet for a change yeah because when
chaos is your drug
peace feels very very stressful
okay
and it's learning how do I learn how is
this something you have to practice over
time that's what DBT is you're gonna
have to practice
feeling enraged and letting it run
through you
and then going okay what's the reality
here this guy loves me he's not going
anywhere
um
I am enraged I'm gonna take a break I'm
gonna go for a walk
and that sounds bananas to you right now
because what you want to do is hit him
as hard as you can
and it's it's a choice that I want my
life to be more peaceful and I'm gonna
have to practice it I'm gonna have to
learn it because I've never even seen it
I don't even know what that I don't even
I can say peace all day long you're like
okay
um it's like trying to explain a
dinosaur to somebody who's never seen
one like it doesn't make any sense I
don't know what you're talking about and
so you're gonna have to decide Lynn is
worth a less electrified life
and I need you to hear me say I think
you're worth that
you're a therapist thinks you're worth
that
and the crummy thing about being an
adult and caring about people is we
can't make you do that you have to
choose
and what I'll tell you is you have
exceeded your capacity to handle this by
yourself
not in those words but uh you're not the
first person to tell me that or at least
people around me are aware that I'm at a
heightened State okay
and that I'm struggling yes
call today I feel bad though my family
doesn't always know how to help me I
know but I always try to tell people
like I'm not expecting people to like
have solutions for me all I ask is that
you sit with me while I'm going through
it and I feel like a lot of people have
figured that out but I feel like there's
some people in my life that haven't
quite
checked up on that here's here's the
hard thing they get to choose that
they get to choose that and sometimes
our rage and our
are lashing out and are yelling and
screaming is
a way we can buffer sadness
because our bodies don't know how to
feel sad because last time we felt sad
dad moved out
and last time we felt sad grandma died
and last time we felt sad dad passed
away and last time he felt sad mom was
just checked out a zombie
and so your body's created some really
powerful strategies for not being sad
could you tend to find it a lot that
feeling try to numb it out with
something else sometimes it's a black
hole right
yeah and you can't go through you can't
go down that hole alone I need you to
hear me I need you to promise me you
will call somebody today
I will
no say I love Lynn enough
that I will call somebody and get help
today
enough but I will call somebody today
I'm proud of you what you're about to
embark on is gonna be hard and it's
gonna be something you're gonna have to
grind through a little bit and you're
gonna be brave and I'm really really
proud of you
I appreciate that Dr Dunn is it cool
really cool
are you gonna hang up and be like that
guy's the worst podcaster ever because
it'd be a very borderline thing to do
gosh no no no no no I I was surprised
you guys even picked my question I
honestly thought it was going to get
lost in a fee of a thousand questions
awesome I'm quite honored not really
good at what you do I'm honored that you
uh
trust me I have a I have a a deep heart
for
folks with borderline
because it's a tough tough tough road to
Hope and the thing that you need more
than anything is peace and relationships
and the hardest thing in the world to
come by is peace and relationships and
it's hard to be in relationship with
somebody with borderline it's hard it's
hard to love somebody that's that is
um so back and forth all the time right
you know that and or it's hard to be so
deeply in love and to get hit in the
face hit in the face or to be told I I
can't breathe without you that's how
much I love you and then 30 minutes
later it's like I hate you right it's
hard
um yet it is so powerful and so I've got
a special place in my in my heart for
folks uh who are struggling with this
and my oldest
friend on planet Earth is a TBI Survivor
a traumatic brain injury Survivor and so
I've got a heart for that so
um I'm grateful for you for for your
trust and I'm more so than that I'm
really grateful that you're going to
call today and get somebody that's going
to walk alongside you get a whole team
um it's Inpatient time and we're gonna
go spend some time getting some rest and
getting the help that we need I'm
grateful for you Lynn